merci après des mois de tensions le
milieu de la désintoxication semblent
satisfaits de la solution trouvée
je t'ai mis là je suis content ça fait
un an qu'on travaille le dossier j'avais
des membres qu'avec de difficulté puis
je pense qu'ils vont pouvoir respirer
québec promet d investissement de 6
millions une somme qui sera versée
directement au centre pour traiter des
assistés sociaux toxicomanes ou
alcoolique et principalement aux
établissements qui ne bénéficient pas du
principal programme de subventions
actuelles les formes de dépendance
pourront avoir une somme pour les aider
pour leur donner les soins appropriés
depuis mai 2014 le chèque des assistés
sociaux qui entre en centre de
désintoxication est passé de 7 100 à 200
dollars plusieurs n'arrivait simplement
plus à payer les montants demandés
je pense vraiment que savoir faciliter
ça va aider les gens à revenir au centre
sans problème avec cet investissement on
pense ainsi éviter d'autres fermetures
chacun vers des tripes
ces mesures pourraient contribuer à
relancer le centre mais la rich dans les
laurentides qui a fermé ses portes la
semaine dernière une partie de la
solution qui trouvait la ministre nie
avoir agi dans la foulée la fermeture de
mails eric mais il fallait prendre le
temps de tout le garde des sceaux pour
régler les choses en deux minutes parce
que si c'était magique comme ça ça
serait tellement facile le gouvernement
semble avoir trouvé une solution
acceptable pour les centres de
désintoxication tout en désamorçant une
bombe à retardement qui aurait pu donner
des munitions aux adversaires du
gouvernement qui veulent dénoncer la
rigueur budgétaire
ici david gentilles radio canada
saguenay